[Música]
los casos globales de coronavirus
superaron los 100 millones mientras los
países luchan contra la pandemia con
escasez de vacunas la tercera ola sigue
golpeando con dureza en europa donde
también las variantes del virus se están
llevando a los gobiernos a extremar
nuevamente las medidas
la pandemia tampoco da tregua en américa
latina méxico cuyo presidente se
recupera del coronavirus superó los 150
mil fallecimientos cuba adopta nuevas
medidas restrictivas para frenar su
avance y perú anuncia cuarentena en diez
regiones durante dos semanas y
militarizar a su frontera con ecuador
en la recta final para su vencimiento la
cámara baja del parlamento ruso ratificó
la extensión del tratado de armas
nucleares start un día después de la
llamada telefónica entre joe biden y
vladimir putin los legisladores rusos
votaron por unanimidad para extenderlo
por cinco años más
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina y de todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria también venidos del mundo
sobrepasó los 100 millones de contagios
de kobe 19 la carrera por las vacunas
prosigue y la aparición de variantes
aumenta la preocupación en europa el
aumento exponencial en el número de
positivos sigue sin dar tregua y varios
países redoblan sus restricciones en
alemania la canciller angela merkel
estudia reducir a casi cero los vuelos
internacionales y restringir al máximo
los viajes no esenciales al país francia
rebasó los 74 mil fallecimientos
mientras sigue creciendo el número de
hospitalizaciones en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos lo que aumenta la
posibilidad de un tercer cierre nacional
en países como portugal bélgica y países
bajos se anuncian nuevas medidas y reino
unido- es el primer país del continente
en superar los 100.000 muertos por el
comité sima escuchamos al primer
ministro británico wiggins
al estar lamento profundamente cada vida
que se ha perdido y por supuesto como
primer ministro asumo toda la
responsabilidad de todo lo que ha hecho
el gobierno lo que puedo decirles es que
realmente hicimos todo lo que pudimos y
seguimos haciendo todo lo que podamos
para minimizar la pérdida de vidas y
minimizar el sufrimiento en lo que ha
sido una etapa muy dura y una crisis muy
difícil para nuestro país crisis y en
medio de los retrasos de la producción
de vacunas la farmacéutica francesa
sanofi anunció una alianza con su rival
estadounidense países para acelerar la
producción del fármaco que esa firma
desarrolla junto a bayonne tec esto sin
que la compañía francesa abandone los
planes para su propia vacuna que prevé
tener lista hacia fin de este año veamos
el informe
hace un mes el gigante farmacéutico
francés sanofi anunció un retraso en su
vacuna contra el hobbit 19 ahora se ha
aliado con su competidor estadounidense
the fighter para incrementar la
producción de la vacuna de esa firma
vamos a trabajar con ellos en su empresa
alemana en frankfurt cerca de su socio
vaya un tec esperamos producir alrededor
de 100 millones de dosis para ellos
antes de fin de año empezando en verano
ya que la sociedad está destinada a
agilizar el proceso de fabricación al
permitir que facer se enfoque en
desarrollar la vacuna mientras sanofi se
encarga del envasado del producto tras
los recientes retrasos en la producción
de facer y astrazéneca el anuncio puede
ser música para los oídos de los países
de la unión europea sin embargo se
necesita la aprobación de la autoridad
sanitaria del bloque por lo que nada
ocurriría antes de julio la cadena de
producción de facer puede tener la
capacidad de producir la vacuna pero no
necesariamente de ponerla en viales pero
sanofi puede ayudar a cerrar la brecha
sin perder demasiado tiempo de luz
dijo
sanofi también está avanzando con su
propia vacuna la que espera tener
disponible para finales de este año
y en nuestra serie de france 24 de esta
semana les hemos traído unos informes
sobre la salud mental de los jóvenes en
francia en medio de la pandemia es un
grito de alarma que poco a poco comienza
a ser escuchado el de los estudiantes al
borde de la implosión por la crisis
sanitaria pero qué pasa con aquellos que
ya sufrían de problemas psicológicos
enfermos y confinados para ellos es una
doble carga triple incluso si se tiene
en cuenta la mirada estigmatizadora de
la sociedad informe de psdeg en off en
donde nos encontramos con uno de estos
estudiantes que quiso mantener su
identidad anónima
q clippers antes un palo
de hecho no todas las personas están
sujetas a vivir un confinamiento de la
misma manera
a sus 25 años jules sufre de una
psicosis llamada trastorno
esquizoafectivo se trata de la
combinación de síntomas de trastornos
del estado de ánimo con síntomas de
esquizofrenia
en momentos en los que me siento
inseguro eso puede desencadenar algunos
de mis síntomas que pueden ser
trastornos alucinatorios o múltiples
percepciones sensoriales de lesión son
software de triple
estas fases de ruptura del equilibrio
psicológico tienen un nombre la
descompensación
juliá ha sido internado varias veces en
un hospital psiquiátrico también ha
seguido un tratamiento farmacológico
fuerte hoy se siente mejor pero con la
crisis sanitaria los viejos demonios
vuelven a surgir
me molesta cuando ve películas cuando
pasa todo el día viendo series o se
encierra en su habitación o se va lejos
sin decir a dónde guapa cuando no
responde cuando pierde su teléfono
si me ha pasado una manera de huir de
una rutina a veces muy sofocante como lo
es en este momento en medio de una
epidemia que parece no tener fin
tuve muchas relaciones con personas que
volvieron a enfermarse que se
descompensaron de nuevo que recayeron
que hablaron de suicidarse como
voluntaria de la unaf am hice muchas
escuchas telefónicas ni la una fama es
la unión nacional de familias y amigos
de personas con enfermedades psíquicas
maquillan es su presidente según ella la
próxima bola será psiquiátrica
recibí varios testimonios de familias de
personas con familiares que se
suicidaron recientemente no sé cómo la
psiquiatría con los medios con los que
cuenta hoy va a poder enfrentar estos
síndromes depresivos trastornos del
sueño ansiedad según la organización
mundial de la salud una de cada cuatro
personas presenta algún trastorno
psíquico a lo largo de su vida por lo
general en la adolescencia
y mientras que el proceso de vacunación
contra el cob y 19 avanza lentamente en
algunos países latinoamericanos los
contagios y fallecimientos no dejan de
aumentar considerablemente méxico superó
otro oscuro hito en el número de muertes
y en perú volvieron las cuarentenas y se
anunció el inicio del proceso de
vacunación en febrero andrés amaya nos
hace un recorrido por la región
empezó la semana y en méxico la cifra de
muertos por coronavirus superó los 150
mil fallecimientos este país ha luchado
por contener la pandemia y es el cuarto
en el mundo con el número más alto de
muertos después de eeuu india y brasil-
de cada 100 personas que en su momento
se confirman se clasifican como casos de
kobe lamentablemente seis pierden la
vida consecuencias de las complicaciones
que también todos conocemos esta
enfermedad produce las autoridades
sanitarias de cuba reportaron un pico en
los casos nuevos de kobe 19 el gobierno
ordenó cerrar escuelas y canceló eventos
deportivos y culturales para ayudar a
reducir el número de infecciones con los
colombianos lamentaron la muerte del
ministro de defensa carlos holmes
trujillo quien fue víctima de una
neumonía viral relacionada con el coi 19
el virus ha infectado hasta ahora más de
2 millones de personas en este país y
más de 52 mil han muerto en venezuela la
comunidad científica es escéptica la
nueva medicina que el presidente nicolás
maduro promocionó en primera instancia
como la cura contra el coronavirus
solo para decir después que es un
tratamiento complementario pero ross a
las 40.000 muertes por el virus el
presidente francisco sagasti anunció que
el proceso de vacunación comenzará en
febrero con la llegada de un primer lote
de dosis habrá 40 en en lima y en otras
10 regiones del país desde el 31 de
enero hasta el 14 de febrero y se
mantendrá la restricción para los vuelos
internacionales procedentes de europa
una medida que incluye también a brasil
se limitan todas las actividades que
impliquen desplazamientos fuera de la
casa con excepción de tiendas de
abastecimiento de productos básicos con
un aforo del 40% los restaurants o pérez
harán sólo en modalidad de libre y se
autorizarán salidas peatonales una vez
al día por una hora
queda suspendido el transporte terrestre
y aéreo interprovincial y los
presidentes de chile y argentina- se
reunieron en santiago donde firmaron
varios acuerdos entre ellos uno para
luchar contra la pandemia ambos
mandatarios pidieron estrechar las
relaciones entre los países
latinoamericanos para enfrentar mejor la
crisis sanitaria y económica
y en brasil el segundo país con más
fallecimientos en el mundo por el cob y
19 un grupo de líderes religiosos
brasileños presentó una petición para
que el congreso abra un juicio político
que pueda destituir al presidente ya
árbol solar o por su gestión frente a la
pandemia la petición presentada ante la
cámara de diputados- es respaldada por
380 obispos sacerdotes pastores y
frailes de diversas organizaciones
religiosas como la iglesia católica de
brasil el país con el mayor número de
católicos en el mundo
a unos otros temas más de 6.500
hectáreas de bosque se han visto
afectadas en la provincia de río negro
en el suroeste de argentina esto por el
avance de un incendio forestal desde
hace tres días aunque el origen aún no
se ha determinado las autoridades no
descartan que haya sido provocado por un
descuido nos informan matías a raíz
los bomberos combaten el voraz incendio
que se desató en el bosque de la
provincia argentina de río negro en la
localidad de el bolsón la zona afectada
es montañosa y tiene algunos valles lo
que dificulta la extinción del fuego
estamos frente a condiciones extremas de
tiempo y combustible muy propicia para
la propagación y bueno se vio en el en
lo que lo que pudo afectar este incendio
desde la primera hora de ayer hasta la
última hora de la noche con condiciones
extremas
las llamas han arrasado más de 6.500
hectáreas en los alrededores de la
turística localidad cercana a la
patagonia y a la frontera con chile las
autoridades de río negro donde se
encuentra el bolsón dijeron que el
incendio se desató el domingo por
razones desconocidas y que es combatido
por varias decenas de bomberos uno de
los cuales sufrió heridas leves
lamentablemente ayer por las condiciones
en los quemaron dos casas la imagen que
en este momento hay 110 personas más o
menos trabajando en el terreno el cual
suma la gente de parque de todos lados
así que más gente está trabajando en
lugar
varias provincias argentinas sufrieron
incendios en 2020
córdoba en el centro del país fue la más
afectada con unas 331 mil hectáreas
quemadas en un año en el que se
destruyeron más de un millón de
hectáreas la falta de lluvias hizo de
2020 el año más seco desde 1995
la cámara baja del parlamento ruso
ratificó esta mañana la extensión del
tratado de armas nucleares start días
antes de su vencimiento y luego de que
eeuu y rusia acordaron prolongar lo los
legisladores rusos votaron por
unanimidad para extender los cinco años
más esto un día después de una llamada
telefónica entre el presidente de eeuu
joe biden y su homólogo de rusia
vladimir putin desde mos con nuestro
corresponsal xavier colás nos detalló
las condiciones en esta extensión esta
extensión del tratado limita a 1.550 las
ojivas nucleares que pueden estar
ubicadas a vía urgencia por renovar este
tratado por que caducaba en
el 5 de febrero en pocos en pocos días
esta extensión del tratado no pone
límite a todas las armas nucleares pero
de momento por lo menos evita una
carrera armamentista hasta ahora no
había sido posible acordarlo porque el
anterior presidente de eeuu donald trump
había exigido que china se sumase al
acuerdo pero pekín había descartado
hacerlo esgrimiendo que ellos apenas
tienen 300 armas nucleares desplegadas
es solo el principio porque de hecho
este acuerdo no revierte otras
decisiones de trama como por ejemplo
haber salido de acuerdos como el de las
armas nucleares de alcance intermedio y
hay algunas armas rusas como por ejemplo
algunos drones nucleares submarinos que
no está claro que estén dentro de este
armamento pero por lo menos significa
una escalada hacia abajo en la tensión
que han venido protagonizando eeuu y
rusia en los últimos años
y para finalizar hoy es el día
internacional en memoria del holocausto
esta vez en un contexto de pandemia cada
27 de enero se lleva a cabo la
conmemoración que rinde tributo a las
víctimas en la fecha en la que las
tropas soviéticas liberaron el campo de
exterminio de auschwitz en polonia el
secretario general de la onu la
directora general de la unesco
y la cancillera alemana participan en
una memoria de las víctimas de la
persecución nazi seguida de un debate
sobre la negación y la distorsión del
holocausto como síntomas de la creciente
ola de desinformación el proteccionismo
y el discurso de odio en todo el mundo
schilling aunque tengas
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que siga con
noticias al momento en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom y aquí con nuestras
actualizaciones televisivas que disfrute
de su día y cuídese cuídese mucho del
hobbit y sima
[Música]